im livestream mit der korona sprechen
und euren fragen zur pandemie so langsam
künstler gefühlte der richtung
normalität gehen die zahlen sehen ja
eigentlich ganz gut aus aber ehrlich
gesagt müssen wir uns noch gedulden denn
bis normalität wieder da ist wird es
noch eine ganze weile dauern
mit am wichtigsten ist trotzdem jetzt
die frage wie kinder schüler wieder
zurück an die schulen kommen können da
wurde ja jetzt diese woche beschlossen
und verkündet dass ab dem 4
mai das wieder losgehen soll allerdings
machen die bundesländer jetzt schon
wieder eigene pläne
das ist ziemlich verwirrend wenn man das
so von außen betrachtet und versucht
herauszufinden wann man eigentlich
wieder wieder in die schule gehen können
und manche meinen auch insgesamt
eigentlich überhaupt keine gute idee
eigentlich könnte man doch was jetzt mal
ganz anders probieren darüber sprechen
wird leichen einer kritikerin aber
vorher gucken wir uns mal an was die
einzelnen bundesländer jetzt eigentlich
vorhaben und das hat andreas hack für
uns zusammen gekostet
am vierten mai sollen die schulen
schrittweise wieder öffnen für die
kultusminister gibt es bis dahin noch
viel zu tun
sie müssten bis ende april ein konzept
erarbeiten wie dann besondere kino und
schutzmaßnahmen umgesetzt werden sollen
klingt einheitlich in der umsetzung
sieht das aber anders aus
in berlin und brandenburg sachsen oder
hamburg stehen schon in der kommenden
woche abiturprüfungen an
daran wird wohl auch der protest viele
schüler nichts ändern
nordrhein westfalen will nach drei tagen
vorbereitungen durch die lehrer ab
donnerstag alle abschlussklassen wieder
in die schulen bitten
in vielen weiteren bundesländern ist das
ab 27 april dem darauffolgenden montag
geplant ein weiterer fokus liegt auf
jahrgangsstufen die im kommenden jahr
ihre abschlüsse machen oder die vor
einem wechsel auf eine weiterführende
schule stehen also die letzten
grundschulklassen die sollen etwa in
schleswig-holstein ab vierten mai wieder
in ihren klassenzimmern unterrichtet
werden bayern öffnet die schulen nur
zögerlich zwar können auch dort ab 27
april die abschlussklassen wieder in die
schule
alle anderen jahrgänge aber erst
schrittweise ab 11
und was ist überhaupt mit all den
schülern die gerade nicht vor ihrem
abschluss oder einem schulwechsel stehen
das ist bundesweit offen genauso wie die
frage wie bis dahin für angemessene
sanitäreinrichtungen oder ausreichend
abstand in den unterrichtsräumen gesorgt
werden kann
thüringen hat immerhin schon festgelegt
bis wann der schulbetrieb wieder
komplett laufen soll ende mai anfang
juni
tja also wenn ihr glaubt das sieht bei
euch gerade in der quarantäne chaotisch
zu hause aus dann könnt ihr euch jetzt
sicher sein in der schullandschaft sieht
es macht sehr viel chaotischer aus und
darüber wie das kommen kann und wie es
vielleicht besser laufen könnte möchten
wir heute reden mit professor anke
langer erziehungswissenschaftlerin mit
schwerpunkt inklusion von der tu dresden
hallo frau langer fragen zu diesem
ganzen thema natürlich wie immer bitte
in die kommentare ich versuche das dann
in das gespräch mit aufzunehmen weil man
da vielleicht mal ganz grundsätzlich
gibt es eigentlich erfahrung mit einer
situation wie wir sie jetzt haben das
dann schüler irgendwann wieder langsam
in die schulen zurückkehren sollen
aber wir haben ja keine ferien sondern
wir befinden uns mitten in einer krise
das uns auch häufig komponiert wurde und
so befinden sich die kinder auch in
einer ausnahme situation wie wir sie
einfach noch nicht kannten bisher gibt
es irgendwelche erkenntnis so da haben
sie schon mal versucht herauszufinden
was die isolation also so eine isolation
mit kindern eigentlich macht also mir
hat es noch nicht ausprobiert weil das
ja das erste solche sozialexperiment ist
wir haben dass er alle noch so noch
nicht durchlebt aber wir wissen was
isolation bedeutet für die entwicklung
wir wissen dass wenn keine kooperativen
prozesse zwischen kindern stattfinden
kann
dass das sich nicht positiv auch die
entwicklung des kindes auswirkt sondern
im gegenteil das lernprozess ist nicht
mehr funktionieren so wie sie bisher
funktioniert haben dass wenn die schule
als alltags und struktur geben eine
instanz wegfällt dass es natürlich
wieder schwierig wird für kinder sich in
genau diese strukturen zurückzufinden
erreichen wenn die paar wochen
tatsächlich oder muss man sagen okay
richtig kritisch wird es erst mal um
halben jahr
na das ist jetzt glaube ich wirklich
eine frage wie diese schule öffnung
stattfinden es gibt sie haben selber
gerade in dem bericht gesagt thüringen
möchte bis anfang juni komplett wieder
alle schulen öffnen in brandenburg oder
in berlin anfang juni schon die serien
wieder an
das heißt für manche kinder könnte das
bedeuten dass sie fünf monate nicht in
die schule gegangen sind was es bedeutet
wenn man fünf monate
dann nicht in die schule geht gerade im
kulturbereich wo kultur techniken
erlernt werden also mathe und dort das
wissen wir die erkenntnisse haben dass
es für die kinder ganz ganz schwierig
wird das wieder
also da wieder in den lernprozess zu
kommen aber das ist auch gar nicht das
relevant ist das viel relevantere ist
dass kinder grad nicht mit anderen
kindern die aneignung von welt teilen
konnten weil sie ja alle nur noch zu
hause mit der familie zusammen war
um die familien geht es auch jetzt und
den fragen und kommentaren ich weiß
nicht ob sie das beantworten können ich
stelle die frage trotzdem mal auf
youtube fragt pascal nach
infektionsschutzgesetz sind eltern
verpflichtet verantwortlich für die
kinder zu handeln besonders bei schweren
infektionskrankheiten kann jetzt hier
eine schulpflicht verlangt werden
also ich bin keine juristin und das was
wir versuchen wir mit der petition zu
erreichen das zu sagen wir müssen
vielmehr von den jeweiligen situationen
der kinder ausdenken und ich glaube dass
es ein stück weit auch eine antwort auf
diese frage es gibt kein es wird keine
grundsätzlichen fragen geben weil jede
situation eine besondere situation sein
wird und ich glaube dass es schwierig
ist kinder überhaupt in die schule zu
zwingen wo zuhause angst besteht dass
irgend ein familienmitglied sich daran
also daran erkranken kann also muss es
individuelle lösungen gehen und deswegen
sagen wir ja auch wir wollen unbedingt
einen konstruktiven prozess begehen und
experten aus den unterschiedlichsten
bereichen zu zusammenbringen und
miteinander zu diskutieren wie kann denn
dann wie kann ein schuleröffnung nach
corona wieder aussehen und wie kann sich
von den einst an den kindern aus gedacht
werden und von den einzelnen situationen
zu ihrer position kommen wir später noch
mal ganz ausführlich
wir wollen erstmal versuchen diese
fragen abzuarbeiten die wir jetzt
überhaupt zurückkommen
wie können eltern ihre kinder versuchen
darauf vorzubereiten dass sie jetzt
wieder zurück in dieses schulsystem
müssen also ich weiß von meiner ältesten
tochter
die brennt da richtig drauf die s11 die
möchten ihre klasse zurück aber trotzdem
muss man sich ja dann doch wieder in
dieses doch sehr starre konzept fügen
nachdem sie mir heute gesagt hat ich bin
erst um 12.30 runtergekommen
ja also ich glaube dass das wird auch
von kind zu kind eine andere situation
sondern manche eltern haben versucht
diesen schulalltag so ein bisschen zu
simulieren zu sagen du musst trotzdem
nicht vielleicht um sechs aufstehen aber
um 78 fangen wir mit ersten hausaufgaben
oder aufgaben an
für die kinder wird es wahrscheinlich
einfacher werden sich wieder dahin
zurück zu bewegen zu klassischen
schulzeiten
ich glaube aber viel viel wichtiger ist
es dass die kinder weil es glaube ich
mich allen so geht wie ihm und ihrer
tochter mir geht es auch so dass meine
kinder sich mehr als freuen würden in
die schule zu gehen aber es gibt auch
kinder die gerade vielleicht auch mit
einem unguten bauchgefühl in die schule
gehen und da sind jetzt glaube ich die
eltern ihren in der pflicht oder in der
in der situation dass sie ihre kinder
bestärken zusagen gehen die schule
trifft sich wieder mit freunden versuche
mit denen die welt zu entdecken spielt
miteinander kommuniziert ganz viel
miteinander und mach dir keine sorgen
darüber wie das nächste arbeitsplatz
ausgefallen ist also dass er darum geht
dass kinder emotional mit dem guten
gefühl in die schule gehen und da müssen
die eltern einfach bestärken ich sehe
hier aber dass viele eltern tatsächlich
eher nicht so gute gefühl haben ich guck
mal in die kommentare hier schreibt auf
facebook so hell das ist ein totales
glücksspiel was die länder allen voran
lassen in nrw davor haben das kann gut
gehen kann aber auch ganz schrecklich
schief gehen ist es das wert
und dann gibt es hier zum beispiel auf
youtube ein kommentar von minister peter
meyndt bedenklich finde ich das
überhaupt nicht bewertet worden ist ob
und wie weit wir eltern zur risikogruppe
gehören und hier stellt sich auch die
frage der schulpflicht hatten wir gerade
schon und die sanitäre situation vieler
älterer schulen ist auch bedenklich
gerade im hinblick auf hygiene ist das
schwierig und es gibt hier auch
kommentare die sagen 'hör mal mit den
kitas ist ja auch noch ein problem was
machen wir eigentlich wenn die bis zum
ferienende geschlossen bleiben ist das
bei kleinen kindern tatsächlich noch
schwieriger wenn die so lange keinen
kontakt hatten mit gleichaltrigen war an
sich ist es so dass man am besten lernt
in dem man mit gleichaltrigen spielt
oder kommuniziert und ich glaube also
man muss zum einen gucken was brauchen
kinder was braucht das einzelne kind und
da ist immer die kooperation mit anderen
ganz wichtiger fakt für den für den
lernprozess
zum anderen brauchen aber die kinder
auch unbedingt den austausch also gerade
die das sind hingegen wieder die
schulkinder die auch gerne mit
gleichaltrigen über die situation reden
und damit auch diese und das dürfen wir
nicht außer acht lassen dass vergessen
hier immer alle dass die kinder ja diese
corona situation mehr als sehr war
wahrgenommen haben dass sie auch ängste
haben und diese ängste verarbeiten
müssen damit sie als stabile identitäten
aus dieser krise herausgehen und das
wird vergessen und dafür brauchen die
gleichaltrige und ansonsten müssen wir
auch ein bisschen auf die familie als
ganzes schauen und wir wissen dass das
die gewalt in familien extrem zunimmt
unter den jetzigen bedingungen weil die
unter den bedingungen unterliegen die
familien grad funktionieren müssen die
eltern sind in homeschooling hohen kita
und home office und versuchen alles
miteinander unter dem hut zu bringen
es müssen große und kleine kinder
miteinander manchmal auf ängsten
quadratmetern leben und alles muss gut
funktionieren und das überfordert ich
glaube die die letzten fünf wochen haben
gezeigt dass das alle gut versuchen
hinzubekommen
aber es muss irgendwann eine grenze
haben und es muss andere möglichkeiten
die manche familien werden das
vielleicht auch noch fünf oder zehn
wochen gut aushalten und das
funktioniert für alle ganz gut aber es
gibt auch andere familien und die dürfen
wir nicht vergessen in diesem diskurs
hier gibt es hier fragen auf facebook
nach dem ganz ja tatsächlich der praxis
wie macht man das
die kinder sollen beim spielen
anderthalb meter abstand halten
wie sollen sie dann miteinander spielen
das geht doch im grunde gar nicht also
im ende sind ja nur nur noch ballspiele
möglich über eine distanz oder gibt es
da haben sie das schon irgendwas gehört
wie man das umsetzen könnt oder
irgendeine idee
ich habe von schulleitern gehört die
müssen sich den kopf darüber machen wie
sie abstand weiter installieren und
genau das sei kein lernen das ist ein
lern unter angst wenn ich praktisch den
anderen nur unter einer maske sehen darf
auch die lehrer wenn die keinen bezug
und auch keine erzieher die kann bezug
haben können zu den kindern dann ist es
ganz schwierig weil wenn man sich
wahrnimmt nimmt man sich im ganzen waren
stellen sie sich vor sie sehen nun auch
meine augen jetzt in der situation
sie würden mich nur noch schwer als
ganze person wahrnehmen können und das
ist für gemeinsame prozesse des lernens
ganz wichtig dass es dass es gut
funktioniert dass man sich gemeinsam
wahrnehmen
daher ist das glaube ich gar keine
option also zu sagen kinder können wir
auch spielen indem sie ein meter fünfzig
abstand haben
deswegen fdp warum suchen wenig nach
anderen möglichkeiten gucken wir erstmal
auf die maßnahmen der bundesländer was
wir haben ja gerade gesehen das geht
sehr auseinander sehr unterschiedliche
ansätze wie schnell es wieder an die
schulen gehen soll
was ist ihr eindruck sind das die
geeigneten maßnahmen oder würden sie
sagen dieses chaos macht mehr unheil als
es tatsächlich jetzt wieder zurück in
geordnete bahnen führt also als
wissenschafterin würde ich sagen
natürlich sich langsam anzunähern ist
immer das falsche
um zu verstehen wo wir stehen und wo wir
nicht stehen und wir wissen in dieser
krise dass wir eigentlich fast nichts
wissen
also das ist das eine das andere ist
natürlich mit was wir anfangen wir
fangen damit an dass die kinder sofort
beweisen müssen dass die leistung
bringen können
leistung bringen in einer situation die
sie beängstigt die möglicherweise sie
auch wirklich vor fragen gestellt haben
wie ihre eigene zukunft aussehen wird
die situation dass sie auch
möglicherweise sich weder auf einen
abschluss noch ein abitur prüfung
vorbereiten konnten weil sie mit vier
anderen oder drei oder zwei anderen
kindern ihr kinderzimmer geteilt haben
und wir bringen sie jetzt in die
situation dass ich sofort leistung
erbringen sollen
und auch das ständig in frage weil ich
weiß nicht ob es wirklich relevant ist
gerade ob jemand ein abitur schafft oder
ob es nicht relevanter ist zu verstehen
wie diese welt sich gerade verändert und
also daher glaube ich müssten wir ihren
fragen wie öffnen wie sie langsam wieder
und wie können alle schüler teil sein
dieser öffnung und nicht nur spezielle
schülerinnen da kommen wir ja auf ihr
thema inklusion mit dem sie sich sehr
intensiv beschäftigen was ist denn so
ihr ansatz also wie kann denn das in
ihren augen gelingen diese schulablauf
also ich glaube ich bin nicht also ich
bin keine virologen so das ist praktisch
alle maßnahmen abschätzen aber aus aus
aus meinem aus meiner fachlichkeit
heraus würde ich sagen wir müssen einen
langsamen übergang finden und ein
langsamer übergang ist der kinder
zusammen zu bringen und möglicherweise
nicht in klassenstärken und
möglicherweise auch nicht unbedingt in
einer schule aber in kleineren gruppen
an bestimmten orten das wäre eine
überlegung und das zu prüfen was das
bedeuten würde unter biologischen
perspektiven wie gefährt
das ist wie gut man kontakte weiter
überprüfen kann das müssten praktisch
diejenigen tun die diese expertise haben
und deswegen ist unser vorschlag zu
sagen lasst uns gemeinsam darüber
nachdenken wie das passieren kann und
lasst uns auch darüber nachdenken was
denn in diesem schuljahr noch als ziel
formuliert wird geht es wirklich darum
dass deutsch und mathematik abgearbeitet
wird sowie die empfehlung der lieblinge
polizei war
oder geht es doch ihren darum dass wir
schaffen was die kinder wieder eine
gemeinschaft sind dass sie verarbeiten
was die letzten fünf wochen passiert ist
und dass sie sich stärken gemeinsam
schauen noch mal in die kommentare hier
geht es auch zuspruch anja bus auf
facebook schreibt zum beispiel ich
glaube die kinder bekommen das hin das
problem sind eher die eltern die wie ich
das hier überblicken kann sich doch
wirklich sehr viele sorgen machen die
das jetzt funktionieren sony gibt es
auch die frage was ist wenn der schüler
selber zur risikogruppe zählt ich glaube
die können wir noch gar nicht
beantworten
auch da wird es irgendwelche maßnahmen
oder beschlüsse gegeben aber die sind
eben noch nicht bekannt wir haben jetzt
aber auch mal lehrer gefragt was sie
eigentlich davon halten die tatsächlich
bald wieder vor sich vor klassen
wiederfinden und das haben sie gesagt
wir gehen maßnahmen einzuhalten ist mit
sicherheit eine große herausforderung
für alle lehrkräfte aber auch vor allem
für alle schülerinnen und schüler auf
unseren schultern lastet jetzt eine
enorme verantwortung und ich für meine
person kann nicht garantieren dass es
schaffe all diese maßnahmen zu 110
prozent permanent auch umzusetzen
denn dass sich die schülerinnen und
schüler ja auch permanent auf schritt
und tritt kontrolliert und das kann ich
nicht und das möchte ich auch nicht aus
meiner sicht sind die hygienischen
maßnahmen nur dann umsetzbar wenn
erheblicher logistischer und
strukturelle aufwand betrieben wird man
muss davon ausgehen dass bei zu vielen
wechseln
die hygienischen maßnahmen wie abstand
masten waschen der hände und so weiter
nur sehr schwer kontrolliert werden
können von daher sehe ich fast keine
andere möglichkeit als
eine art schichtbetrieb a und b wochen
und eben auch die frage danach inwiefern
analoge und digitale strukturen
miteinander korrespondieren können so
dass es eben nicht so viele präsenz tage
und stunden auf einmal gibt ja also
soweit die lehrer aus der praxis die
sich bald tatsächlich da wieder finden
da höre ich viele fragezeichen
viele fragezeichen haben wir auch hier
in den kommentaren hier zum beispiel
gibt es einen interessanten kommentar
auf youtube von sunny park scheint
schüler oder schülerin zu sein sehr
kommentar lautet bitte langsam öffnen da
manche mitschüler die sache nicht ernst
genug sehen also da kann es tatsächlich
auch gerade vielleicht so in der
pubertät dazu kommen dass man zu
mutproben vielleicht neigt glauben sie
dass das man da den schülern tatsächlich
noch mehr die gefahr bewusst machen muss
dass das vielleicht der erste schritt
wäre jetzt den zu erzählen wie das
eigentlich ablaufen sollte und könnte
die frage ist was man damit bewirken
dass die bildungsprozessen sollten nicht
unter gefahren und risiken eher
stattfinden sondern bildungsprozesse
sollten immer unter emotional
gesicherten situationen stattfinden und
deswegen ist besteht auch wirklich die
frage im raum wien tun wir was gut ist
oder was ist das ziel dessen dass wir
kinder die möglicherweise wirklich große
ängste haben die möglicherweise selbst
an einer chronischen erkrankung erkrankt
sind und aufgrund dessen auch zu dieser
risikogruppe gehören was tun wir ihnen
mit der situation an wenn wir sie
scheinbar über das mittel der
schulpflicht in die schule zwingen
oder gibt es gerade für diese kinder
andere möglichkeiten in der lernprozess
wiederzukommen
und das ist glaube ich das wichtigste
wir wir versuchen und das haben die
lehrer trat auch wunderbar beschrieben
sie machen sich gar keine sorge mehr
darum wie sie es schaffen überhaupt mit
den kindern zu arbeiten sondern sie
machen sich gerade darum sorgen wie sie
hygienische maßnahmen einhalten können
und schule hat immer schon auch
hygienische maßnahmen und regeln
eingehalten einzuhalten er hat aber wenn
schule sich nur noch darum dreht dass
man eine
abstand miteinander einhält und nicht
mehr über die eigentlichen sorgen und
nöten der kinder reden kann und damit
auch in einem gemeinsamen lernprozess
kommen kann
dann würde ich sagen müssen wir auch
nicht darüber reden ob wir eine schule
öffnen sondern wir müssen darüber
nachdenken was ist legitim was können
wir tun was wir können wir kinder
zumuten und was ist für uns ein
bildungsprozess weil das ist kein
bildungsprozess wenn wir kinder
praktisch in eine situation bringen wo
sie aus angst aus stress irgendwie vier
oder fünf stunden am tag ertragen und wo
wir lehrer über zehn stunden in
situationen bringen dass sie halt
hintereinander mehrere klassen einfach
abzuarbeiten haben das ist kein
bildungsprozess das ist eine eine
industrie die wissensvermittlung aber
daran kann es uns im 21 jahrhundert
nicht mehr gehen ich sehe auch in den
kommentaren ehrlich gesagt nicht viel
kritik ich lese mal ein paar kommentare
vor
darin schreibt teleskop wir haben an
unserer schule nicht mal genug einzelne
tische für jeden da geht es ja schon los
ganz praktisch limbo läuse schreibt vom
ziel nett formuliert aber ein fakt des
infektionsschutz führt es doch nicht
vorbei ich habe hier auf youtube auch
ähnliche kommentare gelesen wenn man
hier auf meinem bildschirm gehen von dnt
drei hart gerade zeigen die maßnahmen
positive wirkungen lockert man sich
wieder und danach ausgerechnet einer
stellschraube die maßgaben maßgebend an
der verlangsamung der ausbreitung des
virus beteiligt waren und das spricht
sich ein bisschen weiter unten hier im
chat tatsächlich dagegen aus die schulen
zu öffnen
das höre ich bei ihnen auch so ein
bisschen heraus aber sie haben ja doch
sehr konkrete ideen was man jetzt machen
könnte können sie die mal kurz umreißen
also wir haben nicht wir wollen
eigentlich dass der lernprozess
stattfindet dass man das nicht unbedingt
an die institution schule koppelt in dem
klassischen maße das ist unsere idee und
das pre ist zu sagen schon auch und da
widerspreche ich wahrscheinlich zum teil
auch dem was sie gerade vorgelesen haben
wirklich auch mal abzuwägen wie es auch
viele medizinethiker in den letzten
wochen empfohlen haben abzuwägen was
hier mit was verglichen wird er deswegen
heißt auf unsere petition güterabwägung
in der krise
kinder haben keine stimme und
schülerinnen und schülerinnen haben auch
keine stimme es gibt viele sowie ihr wie
sie von ihrer tochter geschrieben haben
die unbedingt gerne wieder zurück war in
die schule weil es fehlt uns fehlt in
der austausch und es fehlt ihnen auch
tagesstrukturen und es fehlt ihnen spaß
freude spiel was auch immer was sonst
alltäglich ist bei ihnen und sie haben
das alles die erste woche noch mit sehr
viel engagement gemacht aber inzwischen
möchten sie nicht mehr allein
irgendwelche dinge abarbeiten und wir
müssen dahin kommen ideen zu entwickeln
wie kinder in diesem in diesen
bildungsprozess gemeinsam mit anderen
möglicherweise in eine andere
konstitution heißt es in einer
klassischen schule vollzogen wird aber
da müssen wir wieder hin zu rücken
wir können das leben nämlich
grundsätzlich anhalten weil das also
dass das ist isolation aber was stellen
sie sich da ganz konkret vor also soll
man die kinder zwar hinschicken aber in
kleinen gruppen die dann quasi nicht in
einen geregelten unterricht gehen und
sich hinsetzen sondern eher spielerisch
miteinander umgehen also können sie
nochmal eine konkrete idee schon
formulieren
die frage ist brauch ist die institution
schule also müssen alle in das
schulgebäude um zu lernen zu können
brauche es ergebe es andere
möglichkeiten wo kleingruppen lernen
könnten also wir sind ja alle als eltern
jetzt in das homeschooling eingeführt
und gäbe es die möglichkeit zuzug in
kleinen gruppen die nicht die sich die
nicht flexibel sind sondern die immer
die gleiche kleingruppe bleibt aber wir
haben auf einmal die möglichkeit dass
kinder miteinander in austausch kam dass
die miteinander lernen möglicherweise
immer noch auch angeleitet durch
lehrerinnen und lehrer aber nicht
alleine versuchen irgendetwas
abzuarbeiten
das wäre eine dem der ideen und wir
laden alle herzlich ein
genau auf dieser seite güterabwägung in
der krise mit uns zu denken weil und wie
sie haben viele praktika und lehrerinnen
und lehrern und schulleiter die genau
diese ängste haben sie jetzt alle auch
formuliert haben die aber auch sagen wir
müssen etwas anderes finden wir müssen
eine andere art von organisation finden
wo bildungsprozesse stattfinden können
und wo wir auch mit den kindern über
ihre ängste und sorgen sprechen und die
eltern entlasten weil das ist eines der
größten probleme von denen die sich
nicht überwiegen
massnahmen praktisch besorgen
ob denn die kinder den anschluss in
dieser schule behalten wenn sie nicht
aufgaben folgen die jetzt lehrerinnen
und lehrer verdienen
hier gibt es jetzt aber auch sorgen hier
auf youtube zum beispiel schreibt armut
die schüler verblöden aber zu hause mit
ihren handys also es gibt dann ja auch
vielleicht schüler die das homeschooling
oder eltern das noch nicht so vermitteln
konnten aus verschiedenen gründen
wir haben auch hier einmal unsere beiden
lehrer gefragt was sie von diesen ideen
die sie da formuliert haben halten die
idee aus der petition finde ich
persönlich großartig allein weil den
konstruktives umdenken beinhaltet stadt
zu gucken wie und unter welchen
bedingungen kommen wir möglichst schnell
wieder dahin wo wir vorher war also
machen alles wieder so wie wir schon
immer gemacht habe wird geguckt wie
können wir den kindern jetzt das aller
allerbeste in der jetzigen situation
bieten und das lernen in kleinen gruppe
ist super denn damit lernen kinder
wieder gemeinsam das ist unglaublich
wichtig für ihre sozial emotionale
entwicklung aber auch für die motivation
die abkehr von einem leistungs- und
konkurrenzsystem sehr sehr sinnvoll
gerade jetzt muss man über neue
lernformen nachdenken die derzeit
angemessen sind und das heißt eben
zeitgemäßes lernen zeitgemäßes lernen
und zwar vor allem in der hinsicht dass
die bildungsungerechtigkeit nicht noch
verstärkt wird sondern wie die autoren
der petition ja auch sagen orientiert
daran inwiefern hilfestellungen gegeben
werden kann für die bei denen die
rahmenbedingungen eben nicht so sind wie
bei anderen das ist technischer natur
das ist familie der fall das ist
häuslich alleine was den eigenen raum
für das lernen angeht sind die
verschiedenen voraussetzungen mehr
massiv von daher finde ich es sehr
interessant und eine sehr konstruktive
idee darüber nachzudenken inwiefern wir
überhaupt einen weiter so machen können
tja da gibt es jetzt hier auch
tatsächlich bei uns im chat schon einige
ideen zum beispiel auf teleskop die idee
private infektions cluster eine
lerngruppe gleich einen cluster da wird
aber gleich lustigerweise auf facebook
darauf geantwortet ohne dass ihr weiter
voneinander wissen nämlich von sascha
richert er schreibt auch bei ihm klein
aber auch in kleingruppen beinahe das
virus und damit werden die kinder einer
gefahr ausgesetzt also es ist wirklich
immer eine ri
nico abwägungen auf beiden seiten die
frage die wir uns gestellt haben ist wir
haben jetzt gerade schon eine ziemlich
anstrengende situation eine teilweise
überforderte situation und jetzt kommen
sie mit der idee das ganze schulsystem
aus dem kopf zu stellen ist das nicht
ein bisschen zu viel des guten
na ja man konnte das
entwicklungspsychologisch so bearbeiten
dass man sagt wir befinden uns immer
entwicklung des produkts irgendwann in
einer krise und immer das ist eigentlich
der beste moment
umstrukturierungsmaßnahmen so
funktioniert es nämlich im gehirn das
höhere psychische funktionen ausgebildet
werden zu nutzen und deswegen glaube ich
wäre es jetzt wunderbar einen moment zu
sagen lasst uns in den discos kommen
lassen muss darüber nachdenken was
wirklich die die bildungsideale eines
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist wie
digital gestütztes lernen aussehen kann
damit sind alle überfordert in der
aktuellen situation weil wir das analoge
im digitalen versuchen abzubilden und
wir fangen wir fangen wir wirklich an
darüber nachzudenken was ist erkenntnis
wie können erkenntnisse gewonnen werden
die können wir kreativität fördern und
wir klären wie können wir im ersten
schritt vor allen dingen lernen mit
solchen phänomenen wie es corona ist
umzugehen weil es möglicherweise wie ich
das letzte mal in diesem jahrhundert ist
dass wir mit einer solchen art und weise
mit einem solchen einschnitt in unserem
leben umgehen können müssen und wir
können uns nicht wegschließen
aber sollte man das nicht vielleicht
später machen wenn die krise vorbei ist
gibt es auch widerspruch auf youtube zum
beispiel von marcello was die expertin
vorschlägt ist schlichtweg nicht
umsetzbar es stehen keine räume und auch
keine zeit zur verfügung um konzepte für
kleingruppen in anderen räumen heißt der
schule zu entwickeln
aber die ist jetzt schon über anspruch
ja aber wenn die familien sich darin
rhein sangen und praktisch rotieren und
es genauso wie einer in ihrer beitragen
davon formuliert hat dass es praktisch
gruppen sind die dann auch natürlich
zusammen eine eine krisen oder
risikogemeinschaft bilden aber trotzdem
ist das eine überschaubare man kann
natürlich auch sagen wir wir lassen das
mit den bildungsprozess und wir warten
jetzt anderthalb jahre ab und die
familien lässt man in den situationen
allein und die kinder lässt man einfach
isoliert dann tun wir dieser generation
dieser nachwachsenden generation nichts
gutes und wir werden
auch den familien nichts gutes tun weil
sie einfach nicht mehr dieser belastung
her werden über eine längere zeit und
deswegen wollen wir risiken besser
abwägen das heißt auch nicht dass das
die einzige wahre entscheidung ist oder
die lösung ist sondern wir möchten ja
das ist unser plädoyer ist lasst uns
gemeinsam denken und wir sollten solche
situation wie die jetzige ist auch
einfach nutzen kreativer zu denken und
uns vielleicht auch von manchen
altehrwürdigen sachen zu verabschieden
sie haben gerade das finde ich ganz
spannend quasi das digitale lernen so
ein bisschen kritisiert weil sie gesagt
haben dass bildet quasi das analoge im
digitalen ab wir haben gerade einen chat
gefragt auf youtube könntet ihr euch
vorstellen bis zum sommer zu hause zu
lernen mit aufgaben per mails oder über
live chats da kamen jetzt eigentlich nur
die jahres und ein einziges naja von
jasmin sie hier
ansonsten nur positives feedback und
hier wurde auch gefragt was ist denn
jetzt eigentlich mit digitalen lernen
wieso machen wir das denn nicht
verstärkt wo sehen sie denn da das
problem also das erste ist erstmal das
können kinder ab einem bestimmten alter
sie reden über schüler die einen selbst
gesteuerten lernprozess vollziehen
können und auch diese kinder finden das
wahrscheinlich wunderbar dass sie dinge
einfach allein tun können allein
funktioniert aber kein wirklicher
lernprozess wir sind menschen wir
brauchen den sozialen dialog wir
brauchen die kooperation wir brauchen
den austausch mit den anderen
und der ist digital nur sehr begrenzt
möglich also erstens reden sie praktisch
nicht über grundschüler sondern sie
reden über schülerinnen der
sekundarstufe und da auch nicht in der
fünfte sondern vielleicht sieben oder
acht also ab 14
das ist das erste das andere ist ich bin
überhaupt gar keine kritikerin des
digital gestützten lernst sondern ich
begleite einen schulversuch hier in
dresden der genau versucht die rede die
virtuelle welt mit der realen welt zu
verbinden und versucht zu überlegen wie
könnten digital gestützte tools aussehen
um den lernprozess zu unterstützen und
ich sehe das durchaus so dass man tools
entwickeln kann die das selbstgesteuerte
lernen unterstützen können aber das was
hier mal was wir momentan machen ist ein
arbeitsblatt digitalisiert und das ist
ich digitalisierung und wir haben lehrer
die vor smartboards stehen und diese
benutzen
als wären sie eine kreidetafel das ist
keine digitalisierung das ist meine
kritik daran
und sie können aber in der grundschule
wo es darum geht im kooperativen prozess
einmal mehr als bei den größeren aber
auch bei den größeren kick in vielen
firmen ist teamarbeit nicht nur
erwünscht sondern sie ist
gezwungenermaßen pflicht weil man nur
darüber kreativität entwickelt und das
was wir jetzt geraten sind kinder zu
entwickeln die einzelkämpfer werden die
mich in einem kooperativen prozessen und
deswegen hat das digitale grenzen zudem
kann das digitale aktuell vor allen
dingen viel üben na also sie kennen alle
die antwort wahrscheinlich als eltern
inzwischen die ist genau auf dem i
fiction situation ausgelegt dass man
immer und immer wieder etwas und aber
erkenntnisinteresse kann nur dann
entstehen wenn lehrerinnen und lehrern
an dem schüler sind und mitbekommen was
ihn interessiert was ihn bewegt wo für
ihn sinn entsteht jetzt passieren so
dinge dass lehrer versuchen gute
arbeitsaufträge zu geben die auch mit
berühmten hoffentlich was mit dem
lebensumfeld und im lernumfeld des
kindes zu tun haben und stellen aufgaben
wie kurz vor ostern see kresse aus und
es gab aber viele familien die auch in
keinem baum ab mehr geben konnten und
nicht in der schublade
eine große tüte hatte und schon
funktioniert das lernen nicht mehr wir
brauchen für das damit wir pädagogisch
kinder begleiten indem lernprozess
beraten müssen wir wissen in welchen
lernumgebungen die kinder leben und das
geht über das digitale und das ist halt
auch sehr unterschiedlich vor allem auch
die voraussetzungen hier schreibt gustav
beyer auf facebook für dürfen an unserer
schule keinen whatsapp benutzen
datenschutzrechtliche vorgaben viele
schüler innen haben keinen wlan keine
geräte große geschwister die
gleichzeitig ihr dran wollen
digitalisierung wäre ja okay wenn sie
erlaubt wäre
das heißt da gibt es tatsächlich ganz
praktische probleme teilweise jetzt in
diesen in tiffen dem versuch mit
e-learning nach vorne zu gehen und aber
hier schreibt zum beispiel hey ho
krösche mit microsoft teams und schuby
habe ich echt ein kontakt mit meinen
schülern also solche erfahrungen gibt
auch das scheint also wirklich gerade
auseinanderzugehen
christina frei blieb ja das problem ist
so wie rainer s geschrieben hat es
müssen die ausgangsbedingungen
geschaffen sein das heißt manche haben
kein elektronisches endgerät zu hause
max
ein smartphone dann führen die sachen
nicht ausdrucken und damit das ist ja
das was die lehrer von ihnen auch
formuliert hat die
bildungsungerechtigkeit kraft einmal
mehr in der jetzigen situation
auseinander es gibt kinder die brauchen
die schule weil sie immer eine sichere
instanz für sie war raus müssen aus der
familie so ist es mit den digitalen
endgeräten auch es gibt viele kinder die
sehr guten situation sind und alles
mögliche zu hause nutzen können aber es
gibt auch viele kinder die in anderen
situationen nehmen also ich sehe hier
viel kritik ein paar gute ideen einige
probleme vor denen wir noch stehend von
ihnen die anmutigen jetzt doch mal aus
der kiste heraus wie das englischen
heißt out of the box zu denken und ich
hoffe wir kriegen das irgendwie hin ich
bin wirklich gespannt die nächsten
wochen aussehen werden wir werden sicher
uns darüber nochmal unterhalten müssen
für heute abend sage ich aber vielen
dank frau professor landois nach dresden
für ihre einschätzungen und für ihre
ideen und euch vielen dank für eure
kommentare und fragen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten live stream wieder macht's gut
und acht sorry das würde ich noch
anmerken hier genau wenn ihr mal durch
gucken möchte was in eurem bundesland
los ist da haben wir einen artikel in
unserer heute app oder auf heute.de die
könnt ihr euch einmal herunterladen
haben ja gerade frisch renoviert und da
gibt es einen überblick artikel damit
ihr ungefähr eine idee hat was in eurem
bundesland oder in ihrem bundesland in
den nächsten wochen so geplant ist so
und jetzt wage ich aber für heute
vielen dank fürs zu gucken und schießen
[Musik]
und wenn es ihnen gefallen hat dann
guckt doch vielleicht mal hier rein da
haben wir mit lehrer schmidt gesprochen
dem youtuber der uns erzählt wie man
trotz coroner homeschooling und
prüfungen bestehen kann oder
hier gibt es ein video mit harald lesch
über die zukunft nach der krise und
natürlich hier unsere playlist und
vergesst nicht einmalig und ein abo dazu
lassen